Bleck citizen knew just a recognition of
recognition of the term is new it's
happening anyway right you're buying a
little spot of land you're buying a
townhome you're keeping your credit
rating up now you're sending your kids
to someplace better what's happening
that's the evolution of generations back
in the 80s if you had a black friend you
were cool by the mid to late 80s if you
had a gay friend oh you are really cool
that both you were like man I'm hanging
in the club exactly but there's a truth
there because what happened generation
started to evolve those people who were
cool suddenly saw people differently you
know like how teammates each other I
know you may come from that side and
that side but we're playing on the same
team which is the American team so as
the generation evolves the parties
didn't always evolve the Republican
Party failed to engage blacks and urban
neighborhoods because they had a
strategy from 85 with the evangelicals I
get it reality a political party right
red state blue state Republican Democrat
county carve them up you get your wins I
get mine we play we're redistricted so
the parties failed but the culture is
evolving and the party has to come along
eventually problem is the party takes
longer to come along I don't have to
agree with someone and that's not
required neither is my offense or
someone else's offense necessary because
it's about freedom and I think the
people will drag it along which is why I
still hold more faith in the Millennials
then people on the right or left do are
there ones that are troublesome yes but
are there more of them in this country
why don't you do as I do and I've been
every state and I've talked to people
and I see more people who are saying
just let me live let me do what I can do
to get my life where it is and stop
trying to sell me on what I need to
believe
yeah and we're really seeing that now
with the generation behind the
Millennials you know the the 16 year
olds now who are not you know the 22
year old social justice were right to
signal in crowd yeah
that they now their younger brothers and
sisters are now going right with that
but it's happened before see this is you
go back to the 80s for a minutes go back
wasn't a few trades all right
really the rewind machine work this way
what happened for blacks in this country
you had a large influx during the growth
of the HBCUs you know the real growth
you had affirmative action you had more
blacks going to colleges yet all of this
come out of the 70s and 80s but it took
time for them to graduate and kind of
grow into the system so they couldn't
stop the march of blacks economically
culturally a historical voting Democrats
parents are Democrats grandparents still
there but this slowly erosion if you
belong to us started back then so blacks
it isn't new
just a recognition of recognition of the
term is new it's happening anyway right
you're buying a little spot of land
you're buying a townhome you're giving
your credit rating up now you're sending
your kids to someplace better what's
happening that's the evolution of
generations so I'm glad you mentioned
legs because I wanted to bring up
Candice related to all of this so it
seems to me that part of the reason that
the Democrats are now screaming about
reparations is because Candice Owens has
been so almost single-handedly effective
at talking to the it's I hate the phrase
the black community or the gay community
that but talking to black America let's
say which also has its limits as a
fairness but talking to popular and just
saying she always says it she says it's
the least what I'm really saying is the
least controversial thing you could say
which is black people don't have to be
Democrats nobody has to be anything you
you're not born with a stamp you know oh
my god look it's a black Democrat white
baby
right so she always says her message
actually even though she can throw some
fire bombs out there for sure her
message actually is incredibly
uncontroversial in a normal society but
it seems to me that she caused such
upheaval in the way that the media talks
about black people
and that after Kanye tweeted that thing
that suddenly all the hit pieces on
Kanye it's like that same game we always
see with you know easy you should be
under mental institutions a sellout it's
Allah's house Negro he's got Stockholm
Syndrome yes you've heard all about it
you've heard of all but but it seems to
me that she caused such a awakening that
now reparations have become the norm on
the left when Barack Obama would have
never thought about talking about
reparations and and he in a way now is a
dinosaur of the Democrats he comes off
now
a guy that I'm guessing you disagree
with him every policy now comes off as
pretty Center wouldn't you say relative
to the to the crew now well appearances
can be deceiving and I'll leave that on
the table with him because I watched
this history to where he got but here
here's what's happened in a lot in large
part in the black community and in the
American communities I like you I don't
like the segregation but I recognize the
reality of what it is blacks and whites
and any other ethnic group in America
have started to look at their personal
life and their economy and their
opportunity more than they're looking at
parties
so the message will resonate more when a
Candace Owen steps up and says step away
what did Trump do during the campaign
cycle it was blunders what the hell do
you have to yes and you know what how
many people say something's not working
in my life what the hell do I have to
lose let me try something else it was
that recognition that something's broken
right somebody pulled the fire alarm
there's a problem everybody's running
around their hair's on fire lights and
sirens are going off but they already
knew something was wrong so now they're
wondering hmm so what do you do if
you're left then I call it the
regressive progressive left what do you
do you now have to create enemies and
fear and fear works you tell people you
don't have it because those damn
Republicans I know you've been living in
Baltimore with 50 years of liberal rule
and at West Baltimore is a s hole and
this is it because you're living with it
but it's the white guy living over in
Howard County's fault yeah all right all
right all right
really yeah or every time that somebody
brings up I mean Hannity deals with this
all the time you know if he brings up
the shootings in Chicago and he talks
about the black on black violence in
Chicago they tell him he's racist and
it's like well how come when the black
you talking about it how come when the
black criminal uses the gun to commit a
crime in a majority-black neighborhood
it's the criminals fault when the white
guy uses a gun it's the guns fault
somebody please sort that one out for me
yeah that would cause some heads to
explode yeah but this is this is simple
stuff people are starting to see this
technology and social media you and I
are you know on on all these different
platforms podcasts YouTube approximation
whatever technology and social medias
Pierce in the veil more and more kids
whether they're still get in the same
images are getting more images more
imagery more information on smartphones
on tablets on computers little by little
that is Pierce in the veil and in
whether you're in a bad neighborhood
good neighborhood everywhere in between
you know that information is out there
so we have a job to do you and I give
people the information help guide them
yes we our beliefs are our beliefs we
have a right to push those out there but
help guide people to not only listen to
why we believe what we do but at the
same time go figure out what your
beliefs are and then substantiate them
and technology media social media all of
this look it can be misused abuse and it
is yeah but it can be used and targeted
where are you at on the regulation of
the big tech companies because it's a
really fascinating one right now but
you've got Tucker Carlson I'll do my
piss hand
you got Tucker Carlson on the right and
you've got Elizabeth Warren on the left
both calling for the same thing which is
a pretty fascinating political spot and
I think maybe I told you was probably
but when I went to YouTube and I met
with Susan Wojcicki the the CEO of
YouTube in her office or in the
conference room and I said I'm basically
the last guy not calling for regulation
no I'm still trying to play the
libertarian thing I'm still trying to
find market answers to this but that's
that's becoming an increasingly
more minority position why they're
calling for Tucker or war and two
different reasons based on their
ideologies and I'm with you I this is a
longer-term view
I don't want government stepping in and
having a hand in something because you
can never get their hand out of it or
you can rarely get their hand out pretty
much I believe in the free market it's a
patient game it's a long-term somebody
look somebody else is gonna come along
with technology soon artificial
intelligence or the exam and we're gonna
exactly and I know others that are
working on competitive models so whether
it's five years ten years they will have
something in competition or they will
evolve or age out that's the nature of
business and I think that can work but
government getting involved is a danger
because of this simple reason if you're
a congressman it's a two-year cycle if
you're presidents for maybe eight years
if you're a senator at six years so they
think in cycles and when the cycle
changes their solution which rarely is
the one you want is more dangerous
because somebody else can come along and
change it and misinterpret it right a
new regulation and ignore the basic
principles of let it work out and I say
this to Republicans I get it look my
facebook page
somehow just basically people don't get
my feeds yeah for a year plus I've been
effectively shut down I literally have
lost 90% of my reach at times yeah they
change some metrics but I didn't lose 90
percent overnight right yeah ninety
percent didn't just draw right and the
fact that they're so untransparent makes
you half the time think you're a
conspiracy theorist and then they did a
weird way they're playing off that right
they never give you any information so
that they go oh we change the algo a
little bit it's a fan page you're
supposed to pay like they're always
trying to keep you guessing so that you
don't feel comfortable talking about it
because you don't want to sound like
well the difference between conspiracy
and reality for me is probability and
possibility what is probable what is
possible and on the ends you have you
know the reality which we may never know
in the conspiracy I don't want
government becoming the overlord of any
publishing platform however I do want
the antitrust regulations to be reviewed
I do want the responsible bodies with
oversight that we've elected them to do
to go in and say okay technologies
evolve companies have evolved does
antitrust me--that's are they acting
like a model like monopolies and a
monolithic body and our others allowed
into the marketplace which is different
than Facebook say Instagram I want to
buy you that's fine
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell